If you've been following
our iOS news lately,
you've probably heard that
we're now using CocoaPods
as our primary way of
delivering our libraries to iOS
developers.
Hooray!
But you might have also noticed
that there are sometimes
a bunch of different
CocoaPods that all
refer to the same library.
For example, for
Google Analytics,
there's Google Analytics
iOS-SKD, GoogleAnalytics,
and Google/Analytics.
So what's the deal?
Are these any different and, if
so, which one should you use?
Find out the answers
to these questions
and many more of
life's mysteries
on this episode of Route 85.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, there.
I'm Todd Kerpelman
and let's go ahead
and review these three Google
Analytics CocoaPods, shall we?
So this first one,
GoogleAnalytics iOS-SDK
was created by a couple of
loyal fans on the internet
back before Google start
building its own CocoaPods.
Since then, it's been deprecated
in favor of the Google one.
So I wouldn't use
it if I were you,
unless you like deprecation
warnings, I guess.
Weirdo.
That said, if you've
got a project that's
been around awhile or are
watching an older YouTube
tutorial, you might
see this one mentioned,
so it's good to know what it is.
But you know what?
Let's remove this one
from the running for now.
See ya.
[SCREAMING] [CRASH] That
was unnecessarily violent.
So, as for these
next two, you're
going to see this
pattern happening
a lot in the CocoaPods
that Google provides.
You're going to
see GoogleAnalytics
and Google/Analytics.
Similarly, there's
GoogleSignIn and Google/SignIn,
GoogleCloudMessaging and
Google/CloudMessaging,
and so on and so forth.
You get the idea.
So what's the difference
between these?
The short answer is that
the Google/CocoaPods include
everything these other
ones do, plus some utility
files to make your
life a little easier.
Let me explain.
See, around the same time we
introduced CocoaPod support
for iOS, we also announced this
cool new configuration tool
designed to get you up
and running really quickly
on a bunch of Google services.
Here, you can see it in action.
I'm creating a new
iOS project and I'm
going to enable a number
of services for it,
using this new
configuration tool.
Here you can see that
I'm enabling GoogleSignIn
and it's automatically setting
up an OAuth client ID for me,
using sensible defaults
for everything.
I can also create a new
GoogleAnalytics property
without having to jump to
the GoogleAnalytics page,
enable app invites for my
app, and get some test ad
units from AdMob, without
having to the AdMob site.
So on and so forth.
Normally, I'd have to visit
like two or three consoles
to get all this
work done but now
I can do it all in one
place, which is nice.
And then you can see
that, when I'm done here,
I have a p-list file
that I can download.
What's that all about, you ask?
I'm glad you asked.
Good question.
See, this file contains
a bunch of constants
I can use to configure these
services that I'm setting up,
things like my GoogleAnalytics
tracking ID, my OAuth client
ID, AdMob test IDs,
and so on and so forth.
In the past, you had to copy
and paste these constants
for all these various
developer consoles
into your code, which left an
awful lot of room for error.
But now, thanks to a nice little
utility library we've created,
you can tackle a lot of
these configuration steps
with one single configure
with error call.
When you call this
method, Google
will find p-list file that
you've added to your project,
grab the constants from there,
and configure your Google
libraries for you,
using these constants.
But this only works if you
have the Google/Analytics
pod installed.
You see, the
Google/Analytics pod
is a superset of the
GoogleAnalytics pod.
It contains
GoogleAnalytics along
with some of the
utility libraries
you need to do things like
read in that p-list file.
If you were to just
use the GoogleAnalytics
CocoaPod, the version
without the slash,
it would give you
GoogleAnalytics
without any of the
utility libraries.
Now, that would still
work too, as long
as you set up your tracker
the old-fashioned way,
which means calling GAI
sharedInstance tracker
with tracking ID and
copying and pasting
that constant from the
GoogleAnalytics console.
So which one should you use?
Well if you've got an existing
project and you're just
looking to replace the
old GoogleAnalytics
iOS-SDK CocoaPod with
the official one,
you can probably get away
with using GoogleAnalytics,
the version without all
the helper libraries,
because you're already setting
the tracker ID manually.
Now, granted, using the
Google/Analytics CocoaPod
will also work.
It'll just give
you a few libraries
you don't necessarily need.
Go on, get out of
there, you crazy kids.
Now, on the other hand, if
you're creating an app from
scratch, I would recommend
using the Google/ version
of the CocoaPod and configuring
everything up using the new
configuration flow.
So there you go,
folks, mystery solved.
Give these new CocoaPods a
try and, more importantly,
give this new setup flow a try.
It is the most fun you'll
have all day configuring
API libraries.
And I will see you
soon on Route 85.
[MUSIC PLAYING]